oh here's a madison cawthorne video this  was on the floor of the house today  he seems to be particularly unhinged  madam speaker today i am calling for the  creation of a formal commission to  investigate the true origin of covet 19  the role fauci played in its creation  the false statements he made to members  of congress under oath and why the hell  americans are funding the torture of  puppies in africa americans deserve the  truth and this demon doctor must never  be allowed to escape justice  excape um madison cawthron had a shot of  expresso and then  came out against escapes from justice  completely out of his mind um probably  has committed i actually  should be investigated should be  investigated to see  what crimes he may have committed  i'll leave it there